hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend and I'm starting with an
observation here sitting with my panels
son of of sessan Matt gorley and this is
a complete happening that we just
realized as we all sat
down I am wearing uncharacteristically a
a green kind of Hoodie olive green
sweatshirt that I never wear and I I
just put it on Waltz in Sona you are
wearing the exact same color yeah in
like a what is that a like an Overcoat
it's like a trench coat trench coat and
then over here gorle just walked off the
set of mash and he's wearing uh I guess
think in the role of radar O'Reilly and
uh you are wearing uh the exact same
green you too and then I'm noticing that
we're sitting on the exact same green
pillows and that the chairs are the
exact same color olive drab green yeah
and it's almost as if I think if when
this
airs will just be faces floating yeah
zip up your jacket we're going to look
like three floating heads three floating
heads just doing a podcast I mean of
course I'm we're talking about yes this
is a an audio medium but I know that
people look at the clips so if you want
to check out the clip of now what could
we do don't we have to is anyone
actually going to key us out or we need
we look stupid we we're just sing back
and forth looks smart I I worry hold on
I worry with that there's probably nor
more technology needed
here that that the background also has
to be all green and then some kind of
does anyone here understand the
technology Eduardo do you understand it
or does bla understand it what what
would we need to do to make our heads
just float uh I understand it I mean
basically it would be it because there's
a a black background we would key out
the green so it would just be your heads
on a on a see-through box so we could we
could make we could key out the green is
this going to cost us like thousands of
dollars no not at all prob my add the
black the the background I'm going to
cover up yeah if you cover up your arms
cover up your arms and your hands I
can't put under the table this jacket is
very small on me so it's already up half
my that jacket doesn't fit you did you
steal that did you steal that jacket off
a corpse steal did you steal that jacket
off a corpse off a corpse no I didn't
steal things from corpses I uh thing I
bought
I love getting I don't steal things from
corpses you know that what I love about
Sona she has
standards she has standards that's the
only time she could say I didn't steal
if they're breathing then I'm
leaving yeah keep doing whatever that is
well listen I'm just saying we're trying
to create we don't have a big budget
here but we're creating a a cool spooky
Optical image of our heads yeah 3 days
after Halloween this is great yeah and
it'll probably air long after for that
Grim grin Ghost come out to
socialize You Haunted Mansion the three
heads in the haunted man yeah not all of
us did time
professionally in an amusement park you
act like come on guys you with me come
on guys the song You Hear 75,000 times a
day when you work at an amusement park
gave it your all too in that
performance you know what I like I bear
my soul for you two and this is
what I
get well anyway we should probably uh
quit doing this it seems dumb what do
you think we should move on with the
show we should but you know what we
should everybody should head over to
YouTube oh for a visual treat you mean
head as in pun head over to YouTube cuz
we're floating heads Grim Grinning
Ghosts come out to
socialize you right now I he's the worst
you are the worst usually love you oh no
you guys haven't heard I'm a little
great guy okay all right well anyway uh
I'm saying just go to YouTube I'm not
saying to watch this I'm just saying go
to YouTube yeah go to YouTube away from
this don't listen to this go on
YouTube right now certainly there's
something you look look up a great
Olympic skiing fail do not look at any
of this of our floating
head